with both why the notes from the Russian
prime minister emphasized the need to strengthen
cooperation within the framework of the union
state and at a government meeting they
discussed how to maintain accessibility
through, for example,
now this crime is happening in Ukraine
and Russia is the aggressor country and the
responsibility for this aggression lies on the
conscience of only one person and this
man vladimir putin wash yourself ukrainian
my mother is russian and they have never been
enemies and this necklace around my neck as a
symbol of the fact that russia must immediately
stop the fratricidal war and
our fraternal peoples will still be able to face them
unfortunately in recent years I worked on the
first channel doing Kremlin
propaganda  and I am now very ashamed of
it, ashamed of allowing me to tell
lies from the TV screen, ashamed of
allowing me to zombify Russian people,
we were silent in 2014, when all this was
just beginning, we did not go to rallies
when the Kremlin poisoned Navalny, we
just silently watched it  anti
h  human regime and now the
whole world has turned away from us and another 10 generations of
our descendants will not be washed away from the shame of
this fratricidal war, we are Russian
people who think and are smart only in our
power to stop all this madness
come out at the rally do not be afraid
they cannot imprison us all